Her low freak bitches.
He is a wizard.
I,
I take my hat off to them,
you know,
uh,
Angela Dundee.
Sure.
He used to come and see me in west
palm all the time and he knew that I,
you know,
my head,
I had like some history of boxing and
my family and he brought me this great
picture of all the Philly
fighters and I was at the,
at the dinner with him one night and
I started picking his brain a little.
I said,
who was the baddest motherfucker?
Bolam so who do you think of all the
guys that you saw or which could beat
anybody?
He goes,
Sonny Liston,
hands down.
Wow.
He said everybody was
afraid of him and he said,
you know,
he was,
yeah,
there's a lot of problems.
Whatever.
I Dunno.
Mob ties.
Yeah.
But apparently heroine and you know,
that second Ali fight
was definitely thrown.
Oh yeah.
You know,
or you could say it's such a joke.
Anyway,
he's faking.
Well,
he got punched like they call it a
phantom punch is not a fan of punch.
He definitely got punched,
but he was waiting for the first punch
to land so that he could just lay down.
Like he pulled that up.
Jimmy,
we go watch this.
It's a Muhammad Ali
versus Sonny Liston too,
in Lewiston,
Maine.
You know,
I thought it was going to be forming
because of his size and his strength,
but he,
you know,
he's a list.
It was the toughest.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what,
foreman before Ali beat him was
a different animal post Ali.
He was never the same guy because
that air of invincibility was gone.
And then he had that crazy fight.
I believe it was with Ron Lyle.
They just fucking blasted each other
in the head and knocked each other down
like four or five times.
You remembered it punched that he
hit a George Foreman with in Jamaica,
picked him up,
not your chore.
And Joe Frazier Frazier pick
them up and the stomach punch.
I don't remember what,
what he hit him with,
but I remember his,
his legs literally came up off the ground.
I never saw that before.
Yeah,
credible.
He was a monster.
He was such a fucking murderous puncher.
I was at the Spinx,
uh,
Tyson foot.
Uh,
Michael Spinks.
Yeah,
we talked about that a
couple of times on podcasts.
I'll scary.
He's up.
Jumped the devil.
Yeah.
That's really what we,
I think we talked about
it at the laugh factory.
I think we talked about it more
than once because it was such a,
I mean you were there for like one of
the most stunning moments in boxing
history.
Yeah,
it was cool.
A lot of people taught Michael Spinks
was going to give him a hard time cause
spanx had gone 12 rounds at
Larry Holmes and you know,
and beat Larry Holmes by
decision and you know,
and he was the light heavyweight champion.
He was a good boxer.
He just had no business.
He was so small too.
He was barely one 99,
you know,
and he's fighting Mike Tyson.
Tyson was,
Tyson was a much bigger,
you know,
in comparison to today's fighters.
He was probably like two
20 built better though.
It's compact and 1965 Louis domain of
watch this because Ali still looking slick
man.
There's still to this day,
no heavyweight that moves like him.
Man,
look how fucking good he moved.
So light on his feet for a guy who's
220 pounds or whatever the hell he was,
side to side,
all that head movement.
You mean you can't look at that.
You can't even touch him listed
with lunge forward with that Jab.
Good luck.
Now here he gets him with a punch
like right as he tries to listen,
tries to crowd them and it happens
with Ali's face to the camera.
So listens back to the camera and he
just comes with an overhand right.
And as soon as he catches
listed on the draw,
listening goes down like he got shot.
I think it's right here.
Right here.
Whenever it is.
It's when listens.
Backs too.
But look how beautiful Ali moves,
man.
It's amazing.
I mean he really did float
and this is the real Ali.
This is the Ali of 1965 you know
before the army and all that.
Yeah,
man,
the army fucked him.
That whole thing fucked him because for
three years from 1967 to 1970 he was
completely out of commend.
Shed is total prime.
Yeah.
Look,
watch.
We'll show the difference here.
When when he finally catches like listen,
even though listens moving towards him,
he didn't,
he doesn't even live here.
He's trying to hit him.
I wonder if they had like a,
they gave him a time where he
had to get knocked out too.
I mean it must be probably the first
robbery cause all the gambling on it.
Oh yeah.
I mean that was everything.
Here it is.
Boom.
Right there.
I mean that this is the fucking way.
There's is no fucking way.
But look,
we'll shit,
the way he's going down,
the way he gets up.
Oh look,
he's fake.
He could see him thinking I
should probably fall down here.
And he gets up finally and Jersey.
Joe Walcott as a referee to I believe.
Yep.
Yeah,
that's true.
Walcott
and something happened there and now
Ali's is tuning them up and then they
stopped the fight.
That's it.
So I guess he had reached a 10 power.
Got that.
He got up after that.
Here's the knockout in slow motion.
What?
I mean,
he does hit them.
Everybody calls it the Phantom Punch.
But watch this punch.
He definitely does hit him as listed.
Moves forward.
He does.
Boom.
See clean hit.
No doubt about it.
He definitely tagged him,
but it wasn't,
it wasn't the kind of punch that
would put a guy glistens out.
It'll probably stun him,
but I just,
it did.
I didn't believe that that was a real one.
Punch knockout.
Now watch that and I'll watch,
uh,
he came back against the
White Dude Jerry quarry.
Sure.
If that was his,
that was his comeback fight.
Muhammad Ali versus Jerry Quarry.
And when he fought Jerry quarry,
this was an after he had taken all
that time off and his body just looked
different.
Man.
He just like Jerry.
Cory was like a really tough guy
who by the way before he died,
couldn't even figure out how to walk.
Like you couldn't figure out where he was.
Didn't know where his underwear was.
Yeah,
he was gone.
He was,
he didn't know,
couldn't give you walked
out his front door.
It never make it back inside.
He was just gone.
You know,
all these target Daumier.
But if like if you look at Ollie's body,
like as Ali goes back,
the thing about Ali was that if
he wasn't training for a fight,
he wasn't working out.
So he didn't spend those three years
lifting weights and running hills and
fucking hitting the heavy bag.
He wasn't doing anything.
I mean,
he's probably just just fighting to
keep from getting locked up in jail,
you know?
But if you look at his
body like look at it,
he's all smooth and there's no muscles,
like,
look at him.
He looks like shit.
I mean,
he doesn't look anything
like he used to look.
I mean he's,
he's bouncing around a
little bit in the beginning,
but he's just not the same guy.
They still had some pretty
big fights at the end.
Yeah,
he did.
But he was never the same guy.
I never forget that Larry Holmes trying
to get the ref stopped the fight because
they didn't want to beat him up anymore.
That was awful.
It was his idol.
That was awful because that was after
Ali had no money left and he was really
suffering from Parkinson's already.
He was,
yeah,
I was already kicked in.
He was already in really bad shape.
Weight.
Oh,
is a friend of mine.
We used to work as Dorman together
and the doc Watson's in Philly.
It was Randall Cobb tax caught and we
saw him take a beat and from homes.
Yeah,
we were just going to
go down Randall go down.
Yeah,
it's fucking horrible.
That was the fight that made
Howard Cosell retire from boxing.
I remember that.
I'm done.
Let no mo look at that little monkey run
our co Sal who called like some of
the greatest fights of all time.
But like if you look at Ali here,
I mean he's still looks good,
but it's just not the same.
Ali just not the same guy.
He just,
his body doesn't look the same.
You smooth.
I mean,
granted he's had three years off,
but he's just,
I mean the,
the old Ali go now to Ali versus
Cleveland Big Cat Williams.
And I've always said,
if you want to look at it like Ali,
in his prime,
when Ali was in his prime,
his,
when he was fighting this guy,
Cleveland Williams and Cleveland
Williams is this big fucking scary,
murderous puncher and Mohammed Ali box.
This guy's fucking face off.
Who is the one that he,
when he was doing a,
what's my name?
What's my name?
Oh,
I'm shit.
Remember that?
Because the guy wouldn't,
clay called him calling him Cassius clay.
Yeah,
that's right.
I forget who that was.
God Damn.
I'd have to look at his records,
but Cleveland when was like,
look,
I'm muscular Williams.
His Mo Williams is a fucking animal
murderous puncher and he just could not
catch Holly.
This is Ali and his prime.
This is Ali,
like in 67 he was asleep.
He goes,
oh,
but the movement decided to side.
It was like there was no fucking
heavyweights at ever move to like that.
No one,
I mean,
he literally moved faster and lighter
on it's feet then most welterweights and
he was fighting a 200 plus pounds.
I mean,
I don't know what he weighed in his prime.
It's probably probably about
two 20 or something like that.
Do you ever see that picture
of him in the Beatles?
Uh,
which one?
Classic picture.
Just him at the Beatles in Miami.
Just a funny thing.
I'm trying to find out who
that guy was that did that.
I know my name.
Early careers got a bit of a process.
Cleveland.
Oh,
the hair?
Yeah.
They all used to like that.
Sugar Ray Robinson had that.
See what the conk they would call it.
Well you know who also is
great sugar ray Leonard.
Oh yeah,
dude.
It was why just shut it off.
Jamie.
Keep that shit on son.
I'm trying to find this guys name.
Jamie.
Hey Dylan.
Jamie's good over there.
Look at him.
Sexy Bitch motherfucker.
Jimmy Ellis.
That's what it was.
Yeah.
Wow.
Pretty sure.
Pretty sure it's Jimmy Ellis.
Did you deal with as a
sparring page and two?
It probably was.
That's probably what happened.
Wouldn't knock 'em out
cause he was so mad at him.
Just beat his ass.
I'm almost positive was Ellis.
I'm sure somebody will curve
back to me if I'm wrong,
but if you,
um,
you watched his fight,
this in my opinion,
was like the quintessential
Ali and this was,
I believe the last fight
before he went away.
Um,
they just had never seen
anybody like this guy before.
He do in those three years
that he wasn't in prison?
No,
I think actually I think he fought,
they fought two more
times and then he went,
yeah,
he fought Ernie Terrell
and then Zara Foley.
Um,
he went to,
uh,
you know,
he had to fucking go to
court and they look at this,
God damn,
he was fast.
Look at this,
the legs,
pap,
pap pap,
and then out of there,
I mean he was,
he was barely getting hit back then,
man.
It was so fucking quick.
And then you see like his later fights,
like when he fought Joe Frazier,
like rumble in the jungle and you know,
there was just,
it was so much slower afoot.
Probably had knee problems by then.
And you know,
he took a,
and from Frazier,
they took a beating from each other.
Oh,
those were horrendous fights.
Those are horrendous fights.
His daughter told me it may.
May is a friend of mine,
his daughter remember meeting her.
I'm sure she was always at the store.
She's a comic,
right?
Yeah.
I used this.
I remember the first time I
brought her up and I said in about,
oh no,
she brought me up and I said,
maybe in La.
I said,
I always,
I was thinking,
thinking in the back of wonder if I
could beat all these daughter in a fight,
I probably not.
Yeah,
we'll definitely not the other one
that they love this beautiful Gary too.
She'll beat the shit out of here.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
And to beat your ass may amazing an
example of how a woman can be pretty and
look like her father.
Yeah.
Right,
right,
right.
You know,
he's got a son too that comes around the
comedy store or it used to come around
the comedy store back in the day.
I don't remember that.
Yeah.
And May may introduce me to
him one day and I was like,
Whoa,
this dude looks exactly like Muhammad Ali.
It was crazy.
And you know,
at the time he was fairly young,
big kid,
you know,
this was like,
I want to say 10 years ago maybe,
but Cleveland Williams was like this
like perfect style fighter to show like
Muhammad Ali in his best.
Like he just wasn't there man.
He's just wasn't there.
It was not nearly as quick.
Oh Man.
Like look at this,
look at that.
That's insane.
He was so slick and he just redefined
what it meant to be a professional boxer.
He introduced a whole new way of doing
it and now like there's a lot of MMA
fighters that use this style now.
I mean it's different because they
throw kicks and because takedowns are
incorporated into it,
but a lot of what they call,
they call it neo footwork movements like
Dominick Cruz is probably the best at
it.
He's the former bantamweight champion
and Tj Dillashaw who's a current
bantamweight champion.
Both guys are a great examples of people
that use this kind of misdirection and
footwork like constantly left to right,
right to left.
But those guys also
incorporates switching stances.
Like,
they'll fight southpaw and then
orthodox and Orthodox south by,
they go back and forth.
I'll get this Ali just right in front of
this dude and he can't do shit to him.
Um,
go to the knockout.
We see.
I don't know where,
where it is on this video.
It's can't be much further than this.
When's your next fight Joe?
The next UFC is next
weekend is a big one too.
Chris Weidman versus Vitor Belfort.
Vegas.
He'll get this dang.
Dang.
Oh son.
He stands over when his hands up.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He's,
that's real.
So that's the way he's breathing.
Very different than the
way Sonny Liston went down.
See that again?
Back it up again too.
There was,
I believe he got knocked down twice.
I might,
I might be wrong.
Yeah,
he got knocked down twice.
So look,
this is don't,
yeah,
back it up a little bit.
You could see the,
the,
the flurry.
No,
it was three times.
He got knocked down three times.
Yeah.
And then eventually put away.
But he's just,
you know,
kept trying to chase him,
chase him,
pumping.
He knocked him down walking away.
God Damn,
that was beautiful.
The way he did that.
Oh,
I watched his fight.
I don't know how many times is this one
of my favorite all time performance is
of any box.
Okay.